methinks it's gonna be complicated -
we're joined now by two of our CBS News
political contributors
that's Democratic strategist Jamal
Simmons he worked for President Bill
Clinton advise President Barack Obama's
2008 campaign he also by the way works
for Hill TV Robby Mook as you know ran
Hillary Clinton's 2016 presidential
campaign so we brought them here to
discuss listen right now it's very
crowded at the top all bunched up what
if anything does it say that there is no
clear front-runner at this stage of the
game Robby you started I I don't think
it says anything this is the whole idea
is in Iowa New Hampshire we're gonna
start to win others sound at three maybe
two people keep changing - well but
here's the thing we tend to fix it on
these polls on first second third yeah
these are all within the margin of error
I know the poll that just came out of
yes yes you basically Biden and Bernie
are tied and what what might happen this
is one word I have for Bernie right now
the expectations kind of well Bernie's
gonna win just because he's a point up
in a poll with a margin of error of four
yeah so you know that I think tonight
will be the first like real data
clarifying information to start to win
out at this field yeah go ahead
I was gonna say how much how much is at
stake for some of the candidates who are
running third fourth fifth sixth that's
going into this it doesn't matter a lot
especially for somebody like Amy
Klobuchar who people seem to have a lot
of good feeling about yeah that's a
momentum
I think her arguments gonna be does she
beat expectations yeah right so people
see her coming in at eight or nine
percent a lot of these polls if she pops
up into the top four and maybe she beats
more she's rivals will get a closer look
then she'll get a closer look that'll
help her raise money and help her go
forward I think that order does matter
particularly if somebody like Joe Biden
it can matter because remember this
happened in 2008 not only did Barack
Obama win the caucus Hillary Clinton
came in third that actually was a bigger
psychological blow I think then Barack
Obama even winning yeah I mean in for
Joe Biden they're saying he could come
in first he could come and fourth
there's such a big wide gap there that's
right well and be good
yeah and it's significant that they're
reporting both of the votes so to speak
at on those ballots and the delegate
count because to get delegates you have
to get to 15 percent yes you might have
somebody like Amy Klobuchar are getting
nine percent in that first alignment but
no delegates right
I find this transparency actually kind
of confusing I'm not quite sure what
message I'm supposed to get out of it
well and when we talk about winning like
it's about messaging right now you when
you're a can't on the ground you want to
declare victory as soon as possible and
get out you might have Canada's
declaring victory because they did
really well in that first alignment but
maybe didn't do so well in in delegates
and saying well I don't like the system
but I got a lot of votes so that's
something to watch I mean I'll tell you
being on the ground works in the Nevada
caucus in 2008 and we had an interesting
situation where Hillary Clinton actually
won the overall vote in Nevada caucus
but then Barack Obama won the delegate
count so we're fielding calls from the
Obama campaign that's like you have to
report the delegate number you've got a
report the delegate number they were all
over us and if we determined like yeah
they had they had the delegate count win
so you're gonna end up having that kind
of mess in Iowa tonight if it's at all
close and people can claim whatever
victory they can they all want to get
some acknowledgment of that well Mike
Bloomberg is not in Iowa but he is
certainly a factor what should what
should we what what is your take on how
he's playing in this race right now
well he's focused on super 248 and on
right so in theory he's out of these
first four states but again we talked
about Biden in expectations if this
sense is the Biden's not performing
Bloomberg's whole theory has been to
build sales and if the wind starts going
in his direction he can take off
meanwhile his polling numbers keep
climbing they're almost a double digits
nationally they do advertising works
have you spending a lot of money on
advertising so the question is do people
flip to him early because they don't
like how Biden is doing he's advertising
in big states they have big populations
so those numbers will move faster he
also was doing things that are very
interesting he's an he did a big speech
around african-american wealth building
that he wants to do he is targeting
communities that should be resistant to
him he's going right at them and trying
to convince them that he that not to be
as afraid of FEM as they might be we ran
a very powerful ad on the Superbowl last
night - I've done violence all right
well it's we'll see what happens tonight
gentlemen Thank You Robby Mook - mal
Simmons thank you both
you